[Music]
thousands of us have gathered to
represent the majority of this country
that supports refugees opposes racism
and argues that we want a more United
Kingdom we want we want opposition to
racism anti-Semitism and islamophobia
and we want to welcome refugees and we
want less of these divisives policies
put forward by the government without
them putting forward safe passages from
some of the most desperate people on the
planet who've sought Asylum here
yeah so what does it say to you that on
the day that you're all turning out here
to March we have the Home Secretary in
Rwanda to remind everybody of her
commitment to make that plan work
well that plan won't work we know that
Rwanda hasn't got human rights we know
that um that the the aim is not
the aim is not to provide safe havens
but actually to scapegoat people for
seeking Asylum and we believe that the
position put for Rwanda is the a denial
of taking responsibility that the
government should take to rescue people
and also to look after children if we
can't look after children to 200
children have gone missing while under
the government's watch who can we look
after we have to sow humanitarian
support and we have to oppose all forms
of racism
what does it say women that we need to
have
a day to call for the end to racism in
relatively doing something about it to
support anti-racism and at the moment
we've got a government that where every
single time people come out and say
let's come out in unity attach them I'm
outside the BBC where Gary lineker made
a very simple statement that we don't
want to slip into the 1930s
and what we got was a response from the
government that tried to use Draconian
rules to shut up anti-racists we will
never be quiet we will always speak out
for those people that do not have voices
to make sure that what happened after
the Holocaust and after the Kinder
transport never happens again refugees
should be made welcome and we should
make sure that racism is made something
that is completely not respectable
women Bennett's co-convener of stand up
to racism thank you for talking to us on
Sky News
thank you